ce sont des terribles révélations cinq
ans après la mort de rené angélil
l'auteure elizabeth renault dévoile dans
une nouvelle biographie baptisé céline
dion icaunais femme de coeur les
derniers instants du producteur dans ce
livre elle raconte de manière très
intime les derniers jours difficiles du
mari de céline dion devenus sourds à
cause de la chimiothérapie il était
bouffi et n'avait plus de langues
il ne pouvait plus rien manger ils
étaient aveugles et sourds c'est la
chanteuse elle-même qui le nourrissait
par sonde
une réalité bien loin du glamour et des
paillettes de la scène le 14 janvier
dernier à l'occasion du dernier
anniversaire de la mort de son défunt
mari
la diva posté une photo avec un texte
rempli d'émotions rené ça fait cinq ans
déjà
il n'y a pas une journée où nous ne
pensons pas à toi nous tournons vers toi
maintenant plus que jamais afin que tu
nous guide nous protège et que tu
continues à veiller sur nous lors de
l'interview la biographe ce conflit
aussi sur l'addiction de rené angélil
c'était grave
il passait ses nuits entières à jouer au
poker à las vegas il faut dire que las
vegas est un endroit de rêve un jour
céline a dit stop
je ne suis pas veuve j'ai un mari des
enfants il faut que tu arrêtes de rentré
fatigué au petit matin
il y avait trop nous revient également
sur un tournant dans la carrière de la
star le tube mondial my heart will go
ron de la bande originale du film
titanic
la diva canadienne refusait de
l'interpréter car elle n'aimait pas la
chanson rené a su imposer à céline ce
qu'elle ne voulait pas et finalement ce
fut un succès planétaire
il paraît même que rooney a organisé ses
propres funérailles il a dit qu'il
serait manager de céline dion jusqu'à sa
mort finalement ce serait elle la bosse
[Musique]
de rené c'est vrai que je vais vous dire
que c'est l'union toute sa vie elle a
communiqué intégralement sur tout y
compris sur ces problèmes pour faire un
enfant
des bureaux et une organisation interne
et toutes les infos quand on explique qu
elle mange ta soupe d'elle de road à
londres qu'un ou deux choses comme ça
pour se remettre en forme rené angeli
etc toutes ces histoires de deux
maladies de disparition d'angoissé mais
tout ça il sait tout ça est très
organisée par son bureau
moi je me souviens j'étais après la mort
de rené le bureau de série 2 m'avait
appelé pour je parle d'elle il y avait
ils avaient désigné quelqu'un dans
chaque pays où elle était connue
imaginé et ce radio dont la france ils
m'ont désigné je suis allé au sud du
canada
la baule si une et cro à fabien on
m'avait mis une tour eiffel derrière les
jeux et je dise oh combien la france
pleurait était malheureuse dans la
disparition de deux renards jadid donc
et après j'ai reçu un petit mot très
gentil parce que sur ce que j'avais dit
sur ce run et tout ça tout est très
structuré travail d un livre comme ça je
veux d'accord alors juste une chose elle
revient aussi sur l'addiction au jeu de
rooney
alors moi je l' ai vu de mes yeux vu
parce que j'ai été avec gas pour un show
de las vegas
non je suis pas du tout indique mai mais
lui il jouait vraiment des sommes
considérables
tous les soirs on parle de 1 million de
dollars par soir je sais pas combien ces
derniers ont gagné par soir mais il se
dit que par que certains soirs la
balance était en défaveur de célyne
durand en même temps c'était son
occupation sa vie voilà il se savait
très malade et je pense que céline était
généreuse dans ce sens là aussi son
bocal son lieu de ça pas devenu senior
non plus je crois qu'il avait cette
forme d'intelligence entre eux aussi et
ça fonctionnait comme ça mais mais en
même temps on n'est pas surpris quoi
franchement non est ce que c'est vrai
cette détente que c'est lui qui lui a
demandé d'aller à vegas pour chanter
parce qu'il voulait se rapprocher des
détails le jeune amant non ah oui non
pays c'est que vegas avait consacré à
lui se presser mais parce que rené
c'était là
les rations elvis elvis avait fait des
shows avec gaza partir 68 pratiquement
jusqu'à la fin de sa carrière 77 et donc
c'était la consécration vegas donc il
voulait absolument la sacrée à vegas
alors à la fois pour sa carrière mais en
même temps pour être sur place et jouer
aux plus grandes tables de jeu d'abba et
parce que c'est pas un peu une fin de
carrière parce que quand on s'est
réveillé à c'est pas qu'on est un petit
peu mise sur le côté parce que britney
spear par exemple c'était elle a choisi
ça au moment où ça n'allait pas très
bien pendant tout le monde n'est pas les
ossements de brothers ou quand vous
allez à vegas moi j'y suis allé encore
il ya deux ans il y avait donné
ossements des maris sa soeur sur la
façade
parce qu ils tous les soirs il chante au
casino mais eux c'est une fin de
parcours
quelque part c'est plus les ossements de
brothers qui vendait des millions de
disques entre 74 et 78 bon mais britney
ça peut rebondir à l'histoire
je suis pas inquiet non il ya des c'est
aussi ça fait partie de la carrière mon
départ est stewart que j'ai vu sur scène
à vegas il ya deux ans c'est lui qui
remplaçait et céline un moment donné
quand céline prenez son congé et voilà
bombard aussi roanne ça peut être une
fin de carrière pour autistes évidemment
on est d'accord et les détails un peu
croustillants qui a dans le livre le
fait qu'il ait plus de langues qui se
nourrissait avec justice pour hisser à
la paille s'est passé à l'américaine en
france on serait choqué par ça moi je me
souviens quand j'ai raconté minute par
minute la mort de claude françois moment
donné il ya des gens qui ont été
choquées j'ai arrêté de raconter les
détails de sa disparition de sa vraie
disparition alors que les américains
n'ont pas cette fenêtre là moi je suis
né ça montre sa force je suis déjà comme
la force qu'elle a parce qu'on la sait
critiqués en disant qu'elle est mince et
tout ça qu'elle est raisonnable et là
elle a soutenu son mari alors qu'il ya
une ambiguïté sourd il était muet elle
veut lui donner à manger par par le son
à leur puce
puis dire aux infirmiers de s'en occuper
non elle voulait absolument de s'en
occuper donc l'amour très fort entre les
deux est à + après là elle partait sur
scène chanter chanter elle revenait est
leur donner à manger à son mari il n'y a
pas beaucoup de bien il ya une notion de
km2 sorte de dévotion comme un diable de
céline dion
oui mais en même temps lui dois
tellement 100 villes à nady marnais il a
mené tous les paroliers tous les grands
artistes autour d'elle et cetera il a
vraiment porté tout ça et là hypothéquer
sa propriété enfin attention ça et c'est
une vraie histoire et elle est
intelligente c'est une elle sait bien
que c'est un homme brillant juste on est
très rapidement les gens ne joue pas est
ce que un spectacle sur deux était en
playback pour sceller l'union à vegas
pour propos des savoirs pas du tout
j'avais entendu non non tu as aussi un
nom impôts c'est impossible d'avancer au
compost d'accord impôts cg1 écrit elle
chante les